[MUSIC PLAYING]
GISELE CASTRO: Good
afternoon, everyone.
It is an absolute
pleasure being here today
as we celebrate
Black History Month.
There's so much to celebrate.
And then, as Jenny
said, there's so much
work that we need to do.
Good afternoon, I'm Gisele
Castro, the Executive Director
of Exalt Youth.
We are an educational
internship program
that serves young
people who are involved
in the juvenile justice
system in New York City.
And our model is very simple.
It's an educational
internship program.
However, it is
how we do our work
that we have been able
to have 99% of our youth
engage in school,
moving on to graduation,
and going off to
college for those
who are inclined to do so.
And as Jenny said, you
know, 2% of our kids
are not reconvicted of a crime.
And more importantly, for those
who come into our organization
with an open court
case, most of them,
their cases are dismissed.
The reason to this is our work.
It is our appeal.
It is that we come with
a large group of people
who are interested in
ensuring that we bring equity
and justice to our youth.
I want to thank you
once again for being
here with us this afternoon.
And I want to introduce our
Director of Programs, Brian
Lewis, who's going to
introduce our youth
and also give us
all an opportunity
to understand the challenges
that our youth face
with our production of "16
Bars of Offending Justice."
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN LEWIS: James
Baldwin once said,
"Anyone who has ever
struggled with poverty
knows how extremely
expensive it is to be poor."
The narratives of the young
people who you're about to hear
know those struggles well.
But I think it's important to
note that the struggles that
they experience take not only
a materialistic and a physical
toll-- which they do--
but they also take a mental
and spiritual toll as well.
In the summer of
2016, when we first
debuted and conceived of
this piece at The New School
in Eugene Lang College,
we were adamant
that we mix these
stories together.
We did that for two reasons.
One was to protect
the identities
of the young people who
you're about to hear,
because they're all minors.
But the other reason
we did that was
because we knew it was
important that we share
in this collaborative effort
of doing what my mentor Sekou
Sundiata called making
as a way of thinking.
So the stories that
you're about to hear
are not the stories of
any singular one person
who you will see on the stage.
They belong to all of us.
And so very much in that
spirit of shared work
and responsibility,
we ask you to engage
in what James Baldwin once
again would have called
an act of radical listening.
So open your ears, and
also to open your hearts
to their voices,
to their stories,
to the things that
they have to say.
Because their struggles
are our struggles.
And now, without
further ado, I invite
you to please welcome
the youth of "16 Bars--
Youth Offending Justice."
[APPLAUSE]
LATUNE FINCH: 16 Bars.
They love me.
They love me not.
They love me-- my ambition.
They love me not--
my color.
They love me-- my character.
They love me not--
my sexuality.
They love me for all the
things you can't see.
Then, they love me not.
JMAR REID: New York has finally
recognized what research
and science have confirmed.
Adolescents are children.
And prosecuting and placing
them under the adult criminal
justice system
doesn't work for them,
and it doesn't work
for public safety.
SPEAKER 3: In 2017, Raise
the Age legislation passed.
However, it will take three
years to go into full effect.
In the meantime,
many young people
will continue to be prosecuted
as adults and courts
and will continue
to be incarcerated
in adult jails like Rikers.
ALEXIS SANDERS: What does
a youth offender look like?
Like a kid who is
crying out for help.
JMAR REID: What does a
youth offender look like?
They look like us--
young and black,
colored of any sort.
Look, they don't care.
As long as you've got any type
of browning that isn't a spray
tan, then you're black.
ALEXIS SANDERS: Hispanics, too--
the lighter ones may get away
until they hear your last name.
Martinez, Gonzales, anybody
could be a criminal.
But growing up in New York,
growing up in America, black
and Hispanics are
labeled as criminals.
LATUNE FINCH: We got the
name youth offenders.
But we're just ordinary kids.
To the system, we're not.
Even if I didn't do the crime,
somebody got to do the time.
How come the system knows what
youth offenders look like,
but in our community,
they just look like kids
trying to find a way out?
JMAR REID: Youth offenders--
any colored kid in the wrong
place at the wrong time.
SPEAKER 3: Youth offenders-- any
colored kid living in poverty.
ALEXIS SANDERS: When
white kids commit a crime,
no one mentions it in the media.
If they do, they'll say
he has a mental illness.
But when a black kid commits
a crime, it hits the news.
Then, they say
it's gang related.
LATUNE FINCH: I don't
know a youth offender.
I don't know of that concept.
It's a white man's word.
They title us in a bad way--
like they ever titled us
in a good way, remember?
Nigger, gangster, thug, hood
rat, jailbait-- any of those
ring a bell?
They rung mine like
it's Christmas time
and the carollers
are out to sing.
They rung me like a doorbell
or woke me up like an alarm.
[CLAP]
ALL: Wake up.
LATUNE FINCH: I don't
know any youth offenders.
I know the young man
who made a mistake.
I know the girl who
fought for food.
I know the young man
being bullied who snapped
from all the internal hate.
I know kids that need help
to be safe, to be themselves.
Sorry, I don't know
a youth offender.
SPEAKER 3: Criminal
summonses and arrests
dropped more than 90% since
a Democratic-controlled city
government decriminalized
low-level offenses last year.
JMAR REID: What does that mean?
SPEAKER 3: It means violations.
LATUNE FINCH: Yeah--
jumping the turnstile.
ALEXIS SANDERS:
Asking for a swipe.
SPEAKER 3: Sitting
on the sidewalk.
LATUNE FINCH: Walking
through the train doors.
ALEXIS SANDERS: Crossing through
a playground when it's closed.
JMAR REID: You know, the police
look for different things
on different days.
LATUNE FINCH: What day is that
day for making your quota?
ALEXIS SANDERS: Under the new
law passed by city council--
LATUNE FINCH: The city-- the
Criminal Justice Reform Act?
ALEXIS SANDERS:
--law enforcements
will issue tickets for
those things mentioned,
which, in the past,
would have been dealt
with in a criminal court but can
now be addressed with community
service and a fine.
SPEAKER 3: And that's progress.
But police can still
arrest you and lock you up
if you are a recidivist.
JMAR REID: A what?
LATUNE FINCH: A recidivist--
a previous offender.
JMAR REID: This is how it goes.
LATUNE FINCH: You're
ready to be locked up.
You're ready to
be fed up-- fed up
with the betrayal of
the land of the free.
They want the youth
to be in darkness.
They don't want
the next generation
to be better than the last.
They bother the helpless
and abuse their power
because, to them,
we are worthless.
SPEAKER 3: The cops are
trained to use their weapons
and assert force on criminals.
They don't learn how to
properly use their guns
or how to disarm people.
That make conflict
out of nothing.
What they don't realize is
that people are getting hurt.
People are getting killed.
People are embarrassed, and they
can't stand up for themselves.
Clearly, what the cops
are doing is not working.
LATUNE FINCH: They ran
because they were scared, not
because you said freeze.
Riding your bike to
the park, then you
get stopped for riding
on the sidewalk.
They claim you give an attitude
then push you off your bike.
They didn't ask for his age.
This is how it goes when
a cop feels threatened.
ALEXIS SANDERS: This
is how it goes--
you get loud on
the train, you're
laughing with your friends
pushing each other around.
This leads to a school
suspension then an arrest.
And this is how it goes
when you look like me.
LATUNE FINCH: When
you look like me.
JMAR REID: And me.
SPEAKER 3: And me.
LATUNE FINCH: Maybe you get
into a fight-- a stupid beef,
or it's self-defense.
SPEAKER 3: You
jump the turnstile.
ALEXIS SANDERS: I
had to get home.
I didn't have $2.75.
I swiped my metro card,
and it took my money,
but didn't let me in.
So I jumped.
The next time they stopped me
when I stepped off the train,
the officers pulled
me onto the bench
and said that the metro card
I used wasn't actually mine.
They asked for my ID.
I didn't have it.
They asked me how old I was,
and I told him I was 16.
JMAR REID: You don't look 16.
LATUNE FINCH: And this is
how it goes where I'm from.
JMAR REID: Send me to Horizons.
Send me to Rikers, and I
will learn all the skills
I need to survive--
all the skills I need
to be bad so I can cope
when I get back on the street.
ALEXIS SANDERS: Detaining
the young persons at Rikers
caused New York City taxpayers
almost $250,000 per person,
per year.
For $8,000, a young person can
be supported for a year or more
by a program like Exalt.
CALVIN FALCON: $250,000
to lock up a kid?
ALEXIS SANDERS: My student
loans for a four year degree
is a fraction of that cost.
89% of detainers
at Rikers Island
are black or Latino,
despite the fact
that black and
Latinos make up 53%
of New York City's population
of over 8 million people.
JMAR REID: Suggest
a guilty conscience.
Look, it starts with
the police saying
that you fit the description.
Then they don't
like your attitude.
And then they take
the situation too far.
LATUNE FINCH: They had
their guns drawn at us.
We didn't have any
type of weapon.
We didn't even get within
10 feet of the guy,
and all we had was words
exchanged for about a minute.
And it turned into the cops
throwing me on the floor,
then ripping my sweater
and kicking me in my face
because I had screamed.
My arresting officer
threw me on the floor
and kneed me in my back.
ALEXIS SANDERS: They
locked up her brother
when he tried to come pick
her up because he was 18.
When the mother
came, they told her
that they were in the precinct.
The police said that they
were being sent to Spofford,
and if she wanted her kids, that
she'd better go to the Bronx
and go pick them up.
LATUNE FINCH: So you know,
I hear my mom's voice,
and there's a cop in the room.
So I ask him, is my mom here?
JMAR REID: No.
LATUNE FINCH: Is my mom here?
Can you go check?
JMAR REID: Fine.
Fucking Negroes.
LATUNE FINCH: So he
got up, and he said--
JMAR REID: No.
Your mom's not here.
LATUNE FINCH: And now
the door was open,
and I could see the
reflection in the glass.
I could see my mom
standing there.
ALEXIS SANDERS: When I
was 12, I got into a fight
by the train station with a
kid that went to my school,
and I hit him pretty bad.
This kid was a
little older than me,
and he was a seventh grader.
He had just got out
of Horizons, and he
was saying he was a gangbanger
and yelling in my face.
I was small, and he
was causing a scene
in front of these girls.
He pushed me, and
I put my hands up.
And he swung, and he punched me.
And I hit him above the eye.
He stumbled and he fell, and
all of the adults in the area
were saying--
ALL: Get away from here.
Run.
ALEXIS SANDERS: And
we ran to the school.
He tried to say I jumped
him, but then he got scared
and told the truth.
The police came
out of the school.
The officer was my fifth
grade teacher's husband.
My school is linked
up to the precinct.
They treated me bad.
There was a lot of disrespect.
There was a lot of
negative attention.
But they had to let me go
because other kids didn't
want to press charges, but
the officers were saying--
SPEAKER 3: I'm going
to get you one day,
and I'm not letting you go.
ALEXIS SANDERS:
And it scared me.
LATUNE FINCH:
Eventually, the officer
did arrest her at 13 years old.
She got into another fight,
and the kid was bigger than her
then.
And she was still small.
If one person disrespects
you, then everyone around you
feels that they can
disrespect you, too.
And this is a problem, and you
can't do anything about it.
So I filed a report because
I had swelling on my face.
And even though
it had went down,
it was still very much swollen.
And my property was damaged.
My sweater was ripped,
and my bone was cracked.
And I knew something
needed to happen.
I know my rights.
I knew my rights as a female.
SPEAKER 3: A male officer
can't arrest a female.
And even if she looks like
a boy, she's still a girl.
It's against the law
because a lot of females
are saying that they were
sexually harassed by officers.
So now they can't do it anymore.
It takes a second to
radio in a female officer.
And since she was
right by the precinct,
there's no reason a female
officer isn't around.
It wasn't as if she was
the only girl there.
And even if you came to
arrest a whole bunch of kids,
you should have
a female officer.
LATUNE FINCH: Research
into brain development
shows that the human
brain is not fully formed
until the age of 25.
SPEAKER 3: My mom
had called the cops
to walk my brother
out the house.
And the officer called backup
because he thought my other two
brothers were going to jump in.
When the other officers
came, they just
grabbed my other two
brothers for no reason.
So when they were all helping
each other to get the cops off
of them, they stopped-- one of
the officers stopped and pulled
out his gun and pointed it at
my older brother and said--
JMAR REID: Do you
want to die in front
of your mom and little sisters?
LATUNE FINCH: After that, they
took them all to the precinct.
ALEXIS SANDERS: In 2017, the
DA's office in both Manhattan
and Brooklyn announced that
they will no longer seek
cash bail for non-felony cases.
LATUNE FINCH: While the change
could save New Yorkers millions
of dollars and hundreds
of days in jail time,
cash bail can still
be sought in instances
where a felony is charged.
And this burden
can be especially
difficult for a
low-income family to bear.
JMAR REID: Rikers is a
really twisted place.
In the beginning,
it's a horror movie.
The way they cage you up in
there, it looks like a dungeon.
They buzz you in
four or five times
after they take
off your shackles.
You know, when
you get to intake,
it's completely terrible.
Everyone you meet will do
anything it takes to survive.
And the COs are the worst.
In some cases, I've seen
someone get housed and come back
all bruised up.
ALEXIS SANDERS: He said
he went to housing,
and his unit was full of a
bunch of rival gang members.
And they just beat him
up just to beat him up.
He's really just
trying to survive
in there and everything.
People is just playing
around with their lives.
JMAR REID: I never expected
when I got released.
I remember I told my
mom not to bail me out.
I was sleeping, and one
officer went by my door,
and he just turned the lights
on and shined it on me.
And I'm like, yo,
what's going on?
Why is the light shining on me?
Well, I looked up,
and he disappeared.
He came back, opened my
door, and he told me--
ALEXIS SANDERS:
You're being released.
You know who released you?
JMAR REID: No.
SPEAKER 3: He gave Frank a
paper and told him to sign it.
He signed everything.
He stayed back a little bit, so
they woke him up for breakfast.
And he was eating
with a few fellows
who were about to get
released that day too.
So they took all his
stuff, and they sent him
upstairs to the next jail
cell-- to the end of it.
When they came, they
put him in a cell,
and they went to go
get his belongings.
It took them like five hours.
JMAR REID: So I started
getting irritated.
Like man, I want to get out.
I want to go home.
I just wanted to go home,
but at the same time,
I'm getting more irritated
and becoming impatient.
Then they finally
brought me my stuff.
They sent me out to a
bus, and they took me out
of the housing unit.
And they're just driving--
driving to get me to
the end of the island.
So I go there, and
the lady tells me--
LATUNE FINCH: I left some
information about a program.
Call them when you get out.
They'll help you.
JMAR REID: I told the lady
I left something at Rikers,
and she goes--
LATUNE FINCH: Just go that way.
Just keep moving,
and don't look back.
JMAR REID: And I just
didn't ask her again.
I went to get my metro card,
which had two fares on it.
I had to wait out
there for a city bus,
you know, and trying
to wave it down.
And an officer saw me.
ALEXIS SANDERS: Don't do that.
JMAR REID: So I stopped.
And I went on the bus.
I forgot the same
day I got released is
the same day as my court
date, so they said--
ALEXIS SANDERS: Make
sure you go to court
before they give you a warrant.
LATUNE FINCH: So Frank went
straight to the Supreme Court.
And when he went
there, they told him
he had to go to criminal
court, so he went there.
He waited for the judge,
with some substitute lawyer.
There, they told him
that his court appearance
was changed to the next day.
So he could go home.
JMAR REID: I walked around
Downtown Brooklyn just trying
to get my mind off of Rikers,
because it messed me up really
badly.
And, you know, I thought I'd
just cool off a little bit,
then I'd go home.
So I go home.
And, you know, the
first thing on my mind
is, let me call my brother.
Let me bring the peace
between me and him.
I knock the door, and
my sister was there.
She was surprised to see me,
and she told me the news--
broke it down, and I'm
like, what happened?
My sister told me our
brother was murdered.
When she told, me it crushed me.
It was like my heart was
ripped out and everything.
I just spent a
week in hell, and I
got to hear about something
worse than what I just did?
I just broke down crying
because the first thing
I was going to do is to
tell my sister to call him.
And it was too late.
And it taught me
a lesson that you
can't keep waiting for things.
And that's why sometimes
I hate hearing the word--
ALEXIS SANDERS: Wait.
JMAR REID: What's
the sense to wait?
I started lashing out,
arguing and destroying
stuff because of the pain
after my brother died.
I didn't care
about life anymore.
I didn't care about
graduating or anything.
I just kept lashing out,
lashing out, lashing out.
SPEAKER 3: Protect and serve?
Take out the word protect
and put in the word target.
ALEXIS SANDERS: I can't
run down the streets,
or I'm running from something.
But you, if you're
in yoga pants,
you can run down the street,
and you're just jogging.
I have a target on my back every
time I go out the front door.
And my mom is always worried.
She is sick when I
don't come home on time.
She tells me to be
careful, to be polite.
Don't get into it with anybody.
I watch who crosses
the street when
I'm coming back down the block.
LATUNE FINCH: I
was just walking,
and you target me, make
me lose all my pride.
You want to arrest me.
You want to slam me
up against the wall.
Warning shots-- no
taser, no baton,
always a spoonful of hatred.
I could be killed today.
I could be outside of
my house and be killed
by cops or by gangbangers.
CALVIN FALCON: And then it's the
black person that goes to jail.
But if a cop kills,
there's no justice.
And you lost your life.
And your mom is sick.
That's going to break
your mom's heart.
And then what?
You, your brothers,
your sisters--
your whole family going to
start carrying guns now?
ALEXIS SANDERS:
As a young person,
my opinions don't hold as
much weight because, you know,
I'm a child.
Even my facts don't
hold as much weight.
And I'm ridiculed for that.
JMAR REID: When you
come out of jail,
you expect someone to support
you at the end of the day.
But it's very hard to
find that one person
because once you
come out, everyone's
going to treat you
like a criminal.
ALEXIS SANDERS: New
York allows children
as young as seven years old
to be arrested and charged
with acts of
juvenile delinquency.
What did you do
when you were seven?
LATUNE FINCH: My best summer day
was when I was seven years old.
It's in Barbados.
That's where my family is from.
It starts off getting
ready for crop
over, wake up to the
sounds of the [INAUDIBLE]..
We get ready, we pick our
mangoes from the trees,
get our lemonade
that me and my sister
got to squeeze ourselves.
Then we can hear the bands
rehearsing for the floats--
it's so loud, you can even feel
the turbulence on the ground--
all the people in their
costumes playing mass.
Then we'd head to
the beach, walk
through the fields of the
farm with my cousins Danielle
and Jackie, eat our
mangoes in the sea water,
play with the jellyfish,
go for a swim,
or even float on
our big red lobster.
Then we'd wash up and get
treats from the store.
These was Indian chips
called Bigfoots--
the spicy ones
were my favorite--
and this type of strawberry
milk, which isn't cow milk,
but coconut milk.
And it's just the best thing.
And that's my best summer day.
ALEXIS SANDERS: We
can't do what adults do.
We can't buy liquor, cigarettes,
or a lottery ticket at 16.
But you can get
locked up for a crime.
When you act like a child
even when you are a child,
people are saying
there's no reason
to be acting like a child and
doing all this dumb stuff.
SPEAKER 3: But then, if you
do things like an adult,
they say, well,
you're just a kid.
Do you want me to be
a kid or an adult?
LATUNE FINCH: Young people
are treated unequal.
I'll say that.
Young people are
treated unfairly.
They're seen as demented
or ghetto or gangbangers.
And if you have a certain
style or you act a certain way,
it's wrong to society.
And it's unfair because the
white kid could be ghetto,
and it's fun for him to be hood.
But if a black kid has proper
grammar, does his schoolwork,
wears glasses and
doesn't sag his pants,
then he's considered the
black white boy, the wanna be.
And that's unfair because
he's black and educated.
Not only are you black, but
you're black and educated.
JMAR REID: Black people are
already seen as a threat.
So if you're not only black,
but now you're educated, well,
maybe you're even
more of a threat
because you know what
to do when you start
to see all the opportunities.
You shine a light, and
you're not blind to yourself.
ALEXIS SANDERS: Home for
me is my thoughts, my mind.
That's my home.
It's the safest place.
I don't feel like my home is
where I live or where I go.
My state of mind is where
I'm free from harm, where
I zone out to avoid things.
When everything where
you physically live
isn't where you want to be, your
mental state is the best home.
JMAR REID: The
hardest challenge is
having that voice in my head
saying that I won't make it.
LATUNE FINCH: I work to help
people in any way that I can--
being physically supportive or
emotionally supportive-- having
someone who can sympathize or
empathize with you on what's
going on.
So for me, it was
not having love.
I've learned to talk
to myself and construct
ways I can make my
life better and see
if I can do whatever I can to
get out the hood, and if I can,
help my community.
SPEAKER 3: If our
words could save us,
everything would be different.
To them, our age don't matter.
For us, we have to change that.
This is how it goes when you
can't get home and nobody wants
to give you a swipe.
So you do what you
don't want to do.
They see you in need,
but you was their needs--
their need to fill their quota.
No ID, age don't matter to
them-- they take you in.
It would have been a 30
minute ride to go home,
and now it's a 48 hour.
Get roughed up for
the [INAUDIBLE]..
Raise the age so that
kids can get home safe.
ALEXIS SANDERS: Where do you
see yourself in five years?
LATUNE FINCH: In
five years, I see
myself greater than what I am.
I'm not sure where
my path will lead,
but I know it will be for
greater good-- the best
effects of me, my
family, and my community.
SPEAKER 3: In five
years, I see myself
being the successful tattoo
artist I always wanted to be.
I see myself having
a beautiful family
with a beautiful
house in Florida
with all the phone calls I want.
I see myself doing everything
people doubted I could do.
In five years, I
will be the person
I wanted to grow up to be.
JMAR REID: In five
years, I see myself
in my third year of college with
a job on the side, you know,
working hard, spreading word
about Raise the Age helping
the youth, stacking my
money, helping to raise
my little brother.
I see myself out of New
York, out of the hood
with a clean record,
finally free.
I see myself doing
whatever I put my mind to.
ALEXIS SANDERS: I want you
to make your mother proud
cause she's not here, but I know
she's watching me every day.
I don't want my father
taking care of me anymore.
I want to take care of him.
Five years from now, I
see myself out the hood
like all my friends promised.
I will be an adult
five years from now.
And of course, life
will get harder.
But you have to grow up someday.
LATUNE FINCH: In just five
years, I might be free--
well, as free as I can be.
Free to drink, free to smoke,
but that's only semi-free.
I'll take it.
In five years,
I'll be semi-free.
"Too High," by Sekou Sundiata
from "The 51st Dream State."
ALEXIS SANDERS: What if
we were life, or liberty,
or the pursuit of something new?
SPEAKER 3: Between the rocks
below and the stars above,
what if we were
composed by love?
JMAR REID: And what if we
could show that what we dream
is deeper than what we know?
LATUNE FINCH: Suppose if
something does not live
in the world we long to see?
ALEXIS SANDERS: Then we make it
ourselves as we want it to be?
JMAR REID: What if we are life,
or liberty, and the pursuit
of something new?
SPEAKER 3: And suppose
the beautiful answer
asks the more beautiful
question, why don't we
get our hopes up too high?
LATUNE FINCH: Why don't we
ALL: Why don't we get
our hopes up too high?
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 5: 12 boys, 12 truths.
One race, one lie.
And we asked them to
share their stories.
Our story's the truth
of this nation you see.
Long before our necks
proved strong enough
to hang from 12-foot
trees, we knew who we.
We knew our problems.
These boys got stories.
The boys got problems.
10 10-hour days, and not one
boy has blamed his hardship
on the system like
project housing,
bus tokens, ticket luncheons,
immigration, adoption,
abortion, teen pregnancy,
rape, police brutality,
gang violence, like
mass incarceration
ain't the result of this system.
But who are we to
say he is lying?
Who are y'all to
say we're lying?
All he knows is his
mother never loved him.
Mother left him on a doorstep
so grasping for love,
facing [INAUDIBLE]
reminiscent about touch.
All he knows is father
never claimed him.
Father two was never claimed,
so father never new love.
Father never gave love.
He never knew trust, and
we asked him to trust us.
Our word is our bond.
We must be here tomorrow
cause 12 boys got 12 stories.
And the root of this
problem, whether it
be the household, or the system,
is that nobody is listening.
One boy doesn't
know his last name.
He's still hoping
he gets to the top.
There are two boys in
the midst of an argument.
One calls his sister a bitch.
She runs out the door.
Some hours later, she
comes home crying rape.
He keeps blaming himself.
The other boy can't
fathom with the fact
he didn't stop his younger
sister from running out
that door.
Three boys think love is pain.
I'm one of them.
Four boys got the
exact same story.
Five boys can't
fathom with the fact
that their mother is using
their bodies to make ends meet.
Six boys won't even talk.
Their tears are
telling their stories.
And out of 12 boys, only
one father got deported.
I'm not talking about mine.
Some fathers aren't there.
Some fathers are in jail
when out of 12 boys,
only one boy has
never met his mother.
Seven boys got mothers
who strung out on drugs.
And only one mother has found
the strength to recover.
I'm talking about mine.
Eight boys just want to be free.
They like, I can't
go back to juvie.
Nine boys, because they
did 10 10-hour days,
want to go to college.
10 boys more confident
than they've ever been.
Eleven boys blame
their hardships
on one decision--
deciding to be the same.
12 boys think it's a chance
they can be different.
One race.
We blame it on the system,
but we, these 12 boys,
know it's our household.
We blame it on our household.
We like, we never knew love.
We never had love.
All the system needs is love.
Though like a one
day, if he loved me,
would he still
pulled the trigger?
Because if father knew
love, father would be here.
Mother would be here.
12 boys, 12 truths.
One race, one lie.
Both just needed love.
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN PRIESTER: Let's give
another round of applause
to all our performers.
[APPLAUSE]
My name is Jonathan Priester.
I am one of the co-leads for the
New York chapter of the Black
Googler Network.
I am an account strategist
here, and it is an honor
to have all of you all here.
It is an honor to have
the Exalt family here.
And before we begin, we're
going to have a brief panel,
and then we're going
to some question
and answer for the audience.
But before we begin, I
think we want to start off
with introductions.
So I'll start at the end,
and we'll work our way down.
And then also, we'd love to have
just some quick introductions
from our performers as
well because they've given
voice is such a
powerful subject.
JOLANDA PORTER: Good afternoon.
I'm Jolanda Porter.
I'm the Deputy
Director of Exalt.
CALI JORDAN-GOTAY:
Good afternoon.
My name is Cali Jordan-Gotay.
I'm an Exalt alumni.
I graduated in 2015, and I
work for the Daphne Foundation.
BRIAN LEWIS: Good afternoon.
Brian Lewis, the Director
of Programs for Exalt.
LATUNE FINCH: My
name is Latune Finch.
I am a Exalt alumni,
and I graduated in 2015.
And I am an entrepreneur.
JONATHAN PRIESTER: And could
you give-- and if each of you
all could come up
real quick, we want
to make sure--
you all gave voice
to such powerful messages.
Come back to the stage real
quick, introduce yourself.
JMAR REID: Hello, my
name is Jmar Reid.
I am a member of the New School.
I have come on to
this lovely project
just to help out
in any way I can.
ALEXIS SANDERS: Hello.
My name is Alexis
Sanders, and I'm
a Exalt graduate of cycle 85.
CALVIN FALCON: Hello.
My name is Calvin
Falcon, I'm also here
on behalf of the New
School Lang department.
I'm a theater major as well.
JONATHAN PRIESTER: Let's
give them all a round
of applause one more time.
[APPLAUSE]
So my first question for
the entire panel really is--
that was such a
powerful presentation.
It's captured so many
different stories.
And as you mentioned
earlier, this isn't just
one person's narrative.
This is a narrative of
an entire generation.
So can you talk about
the creative process?
And can you share
with us what was it
like to be a part
of Exalt and going
through that creative
process and putting
this piece together?
LATUNE FINCH: Being a
part of Exalt in 2015,
I was going through
a very hard time,
and it drifted me
to a right path.
When we started this
project, it was a year
after my graduation
in the summer of 2016.
So we have been working on
this for a year and a half.
During this process, we
did multiple monologues.
Creativity, we just-- we thought
and processed everything that
happened to us over our lives--
me and several other
participants who
wrote and scripted the
documentary theater piece.
BRIAN LEWIS: We also watched
the work of Anna Deavere Smith.
We watched a lot of what
was happening in the media
that summer.
So, you know, the police
killings and police brutality
that was happening sort of like
made its way into our script
and became a really
important focal point.
We watched President
Obama's response
to what happened in Dallas.
And there was a lot of
things that were happening
that really informed our work.
It was sort of--
it was definitely a
lot of improvisation
and collaboration.
JONATHAN PRIESTER: And I
guess as a follow up question
to that for the entire
panel, here at Google,
we think of everything from
a technical perspective.
We look at, like, oh, I
want to solve for x problem.
So I'm going to build
this application.
Or I'm going to build this
type of phone or something
like that.
What were you all
looking to address?
What was the goal
in terms of, this
is something that we're
seeing in the community.
This is something
that we're seeing--
and again, throughout
the piece, there where
it talks about Rikers.
There where it talks
about specific legislation
such as Raise the Age, which
we'll get to in a moment.
But was there something
specific that you had in mind?
Or was it really just, we
want to create a piece that's
cathartic for the community?
JOLANDA PORTER: Yeah.
I think one of our main
goals was awareness.
A lot of people
don't know what's
happening with the young
people in our country.
And I think one goal was
awareness for the public.
And I think the other goal was
to really help our young people
to look inside themselves and
be able to tell their stories.
And one of the
best experiences I
had was working on
songwriting with the group
and getting them to
really tell their stories
and seeing how that
could be transformed
into part of the piece.
So I would say that awareness
is a big part of the issue.
And I think that's one of
the things we're trying to--
we're striving to
do today, which
is to make you all aware
of what's happening
and get you involved.
CALI JORDAN-GOTAY: I was
there at the beginning stages
when everybody
was brainstorming.
And this was a really
amazing process
because a lot of young people
aren't aware of the issues that
are going on, right?
We just deal with
the effects of that.
So it was really just an
opportunity to look at,
what's going on today?
How does this affect us?
And how can we use this project
to tell people how we feel?
I think one of the focal
points of this project
are how valid our voices are.
But as young people,
people just don't
listen sometimes, for
whatever reason that is--
ageism, adultism,
I'm not too sure.
But this was an opportunity
for us to get together--
Exalt participants as a whole--
and share these real life
experiences.
You do have minors who
are going to Rikers.
You do have people
who are living
in impoverished neighborhoods.
And you have people who are
dealing with this every day.
But people only see
this angry face.
So I think this
was an opportunity
to peel back the
layers, and it was
amazing to be a part of that.
JONATHAN PRIESTER:
That's amazing.
And I think you brought
up a good point.
You called it adultism, but it's
really just closing our ears
and closing our minds
to a different reality.
So one of the things I took away
from your powerful presentation
was giving voice
to the voiceless.
And it seems like Exalt has
been a platform to that.
So could you all speak
to the impact of Exalt--
how you got connected
with it, and the work
that Exalt does to make a
difference in the community?
LATUNE FINCH: Exalt is better
than the school system.
It's better than,
you know, being
put on probation because
it teaches you something.
It gives you education.
It gives you strength,
and it gives you barriers
that you know you
could hop over.
It gives you the strength
to know when to leap,
and how to leap, and how far.
Exalt has been a platform
for me throughout out years.
It's 2018.
I graduated in 2015.
Before that, I started Exalt
when I was 14 years old.
So being that I
was that young, it
drifted me onto the right
path and has shown me a better
way of living, essentially.
CALI JORDAN-GOTAY:
Well, as you guys know,
Exalt is an
organization that works
with justice-involved youth.
So when I was
younger, I did have
an interaction with the
juvenile justice system.
But what Exalt
helped me realize was
there was a reason that
this was happening.
And you can look at this from
an analytical standpoint.
And you can figure out what
you're going to do about it.
And I used that as an
opportunity to kind of
push forth, right,
and just expose myself
to different opportunities to
learn about different fields
and, you know, what I
actually want to do.
Right now, I'm getting
my bachelor's degree.
So I'm studying politics,
law, and economics.
And that's definitely something
that Exalt helped influence.
That's a decision
that was made partly
by my experience with
Exalt because there
is such a deep issue in the
juvenile justice system.
And it's just affecting
so many young people.
And we don't know
how to look at it.
And people don't look at it.
And you just bypass
this huge problem.
So this was an
opportunity for me
to learn and just do
something about it
and switch things around.
BRIAN LEWIS: And so
what we do in Exalt--
and Latune and Cali spoke
so eloquently to it--
but essentially working
in three key areas.
We're trying to get young
people to get their cases closed
or get sentence reductions.
So we're working in the courts.
We're working to get young
people enrolled in school
and progressing educationally.
And then we're also providing
them with paid internship
opportunities.
And so when we work
in those three areas,
the one thing that we notice
is the common thread is that
so many of our young people--
and Cali and Latune both said
this, and all of our performers,
and the young people who
created these
stories said this--
is that they feel
disconnected from society.
They feel like they
don't have a place.
They're truly the
most marginalized.
And so what Exalt is doing is
putting those young people's
experiences at the center.
And that's why this was
such a perfect marriage
to create this
documentary theater piece
because my colleague and I--
Cecilia Rubino, who
I have to thank.
She's amazing.
She's out here in the
audience somewhere.
And Luisa [? Strodeman ?]
is also back
here doing [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN PRIESTER: Give
them a round of applause.
BRIAN LEWIS: Please.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
When we created this piece,
we said, OK, you know,
we're going to come up
with writing prompts.
We're going to come up with
different activities and things
that we can create together.
But the young
people led this out.
I mean, they
co-produced everything.
They co-directed everything.
Jolanda talked about
how she came in and did
songwriting with them.
They went in the
studio, and then they
produced songs, right?
And so all the music that
you heard in the piece
also was original
music that was created
that summer except for
the intro song and the--
LATUNE FINCH: Exit song.
BRIAN LEWIS: Exit song.
Right.
But there were three
original tracks, right?
I mean, it's incredible
what young people can
do if you give them a platform.
And I think that's what
Exalt really stands for.
JONATHAN PRIESTER: And I'll
ask one quick follow-up
for both of you all as
administrators and people who
are helping to
facilitate this work.
What has been the impact
on you all as people
who are seeing this
from a different lens--
a different perspective?
How are you-- how has this
experience changed your view--
not only on criminal
justice, but on the way
that you relate to young people?
JOLANDA PORTER: I
would say that--
probably Brian, you could
say this too, right-- we
grew up in this
space and knowing
what it's like to be
under-served and be
from those communities.
And so doing this
work, I think it just
makes you feel like you're on
the right path, in that you
are doing the kind of work
that you should be doing.
I mean, every day we get
to work with people--
especially through our alumni
problem, we're working with--
we actually just
worked with Google--
about how to connect
people who don't
know what to do with this work
and how to get them connected
to the work.
So I think one of the major
things that I've taken away
is that I'm happy to be
a part of the mission
and part of the movement.
BRIAN LEWIS: This
work is stressful.
It's difficult. It's hard.
But every day, I'm
inspired by my students.
And so these are
both my students.
They were in-- so when Latune
talks about graduating,
she graduated from Exalt.
In Exalt, we call them cycles.
And so Latune and Cali--
LATUNE FINCH: 69.
BRIAN LEWIS: --were
both in cycle 69,
right, which I had the honor
and the pleasure of teaching.
I mean, you can imagine.
I mean, you know, it's like--
you see how brilliant they are,
and how creative they are,
and how inspiring they are.
So yes, I mean,
there were struggles.
There were young people
who got incarcerated
or literally had to dodge
bullets to get to our space
and to learn.
And so those things
take a toll, right?
There's a trauma that gets
passed on to you from that.
But then, you get to
hear the brilliance.
You get to learn.
You get to be in conversation
with incredible young people
like these.
And so there's no
higher high, right?
I mean, you know, the lows
can be low, and difficult,
and tough.
But then, you
know, you're fed by
this incredible creative spirit
that our young people bring.
So every day, I'm inspired
by them and learn from them.
JONATHAN PRIESTER:
As we all know,
change just doesn't
happen overnight.
It's something that is done
through habitual hard work--
putting in the work
day in and day out.
And topics like Close Rikers--
like, that's something that
has been in the works for years
and is still an ongoing process.
Raise the Age-- that's
a legal battle that's
been going on for years
that Exalt has been
on the front line really
pushing to make that an issue
that we're all aware of.
And we're seeing now some of
the benefits of that work.
For our audience that
may not be familiar,
can someone tell us what
Raise the Age is in terms
of initiatives and how--
what is Exalt doing to
help prepare us for world
and what that world would
look like when we don't have
a Rikers, when we don't
have a situation where
we see juveniles being placed
in the system so unfairly?
LATUNE FINCH: Raise the Age
is the legislation which
raises the age of
criminal responsibility
to age 18 instead of 16, which
is currently in New York City.
Me and Cali-- we went
to Albany to advocate
for this law in 2016.
It was recently passed in
2017, which is progress.
JONATHAN PRIESTER:
Let's just give around
of applause for that.
LATUNE FINCH: Which is progress.
And, as in the piece, it says
that it won't pass until--
it won't officially be in
effect until three years later.
Raise the Age and Exalt has--
we have been pushing as
a whole because there
are people and
kids, necessarily,
that have been placed in these
facilities that have been
tortured, been abused
in adult criminal jails
because they're younger.
So that makes you a target.
Regardless of
where they put you,
you're always a target because
you may be the youngest
person in that cell block.
Or you may be more vulnerable
because of how you look,
or whatever the case may be.
And that has brung a toll,
which has brung attention.
And that's what we want.
We want to bring
awareness so people
know that this legislation
should be passed,
and should be pushed, and
should be completed sooner
rather than later.
CALI JORDAN-GOTAY: Just
to close that loop--
when you talk
about Close Rikers,
and when you talk about all of
these things that are going on
with criminal justice
reform, there's
a very important phrase
or line in this piece that
goes, $250,000 to house
somebody at Rikers Island--
a fraction of that cost could
cover a bachelor's degree.
I think that's a huge
point right there, right?
How do you strategically move
the money from the criminal
justice system, right-- from
these for-profit prisons,
which are essentially banking
on kids getting locked up--
how do you move that into the
educational system or something
that can help the youth?
What is the solution?
And we don't-- Exalt is a great
high-end diversion program
that, you know, works
towards that solution.
But how do we actually sit
down and think about this?
I mean, the numbers are here.
The information is here.
Who's paying attention?
And who's looking at it?
BRIAN LEWIS: Yeah.
That's so well said.
Please give it up for that.
[APPLAUSE]
And they're exactly right.
And the question is, where
are young people going to go?
And how are we going
to support them?
When we close
Rikers Island, when
we begin to move
young people out
of the adult criminal system
and into the juvenile system,
you know, how will they
continue to get services?
How will they
continue to progress?
We have a very effective
model and a blueprint
for how that can work.
And so we really see
ourselves as playing
a crucial and pivotal role as
we consider-- as we continue
to think about what will happen
to the young people being moved
around from the adult system
into the juvenile system?
What will happen to
the young people who
will be taken off of Rikers
Island and other facilities
in the coming years?
JONATHAN PRIESTER:
So-- I'm sorry.
JOLANDA PORTER: No.
I was just going to
say that I agree.
I think a lot of times, we're
looking to the education
system, which, in a lot of ways,
is failing our young people--
and I'm not using the mic, but--
which is failing
our young people.
And I think the
solution is going
to be with a lot of our
community-based organizations.
So looking at the
people who are working
with the students on the ground
seeing what the issues are
and putting the resources
there-- as Cali was saying,
we have to take the money
away from the system
and put it into,
really, our community
activists and the people who are
working with our young people
every day.
So I do think that Exalt
is a leader with that,
and I'm looking
forward to the future.
JONATHAN PRIESTER: I'm going
to ask one last question,
and then we're going to open up
to the audience for one or two
quick questions because I know
we're running tight on time.
But we have an opportunity now,
not only for the people that
are here in this audience,
but an opportunity to not only
talk to fellow Googlers,
but also the entire world.
So what are some ways
that today we can get
involved with Exalt and for
the fight for criminal justice?
JOLANDA PORTER: Yeah.
There are multiple ways.
I would say that if you
know a young person that
needs our services, you
should refer them to us.
If you are a business, or
you are an organization that
wants a young person
to intern for you,
then you could be our host site.
You can also, if you're
interested, join our board.
And I think there's
also, obviously,
an opportunity to donate.
And we have those
options that are
going to be rolling for
you later on the slideshow.
There are multiple
ways to connect to us,
but those are the
four major ways.
So refer that student, to host
that intern, to join our board,
and to donate to our mission.
JONATHAN PRIESTER: And for those
of you that are going to be
watching, you can go to
www.exaltyouth.org/getinvolved.
That's
exaltyouth.org/getinvolved.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
My name is Mivan Lamb.
I'm a retired professor of law.
And I think the point
you made about $250,000
to keep one person in jail--
somebody should be following
that money when they close down
Rikers.
That should not just
evaporate and go
into the military
parade in Washington DC,
for example, right?
[APPLAUSE]
That money-- I mean,
if they weren't
willing to pay $250,000
per incarcerated person,
that should just
move automatically
to programs such
as Exalt. And that
has to be done via a
political campaign.
Is anybody trying
to follow that money
and say, it's going to go
from this, which doesn't work,
to that, which works?
I really-- yeah.
Thank you.
JOLANDA PORTER: Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
Well--
LATUNE FINCH: I mean, it
wasn't really a question.
JOLANDA PORTER: Yeah.
Well, I will say this.
I-- historically,
Exalt has stayed away
from government and
city funding because we
wanted to control
the kind of content
that we gave to
our young people.
I think a lot of times, when
you are adhering to government
funding, you're not able to
make the young people the focus.
And Exalt has been able to do
that now for over a decade.
Now, because we have that
blueprint that Brian mentioned,
we are looking to work with the
city and government officials
to be able to
expand our mission.
So absolutely.
We want to follow that money.
And hopefully, it will
find its way to us.
CALI JORDAN-GOTAY: To
go back to that question
of who's following that money--
through Exalt, I
was actually brought
into the field of philanthropy.
And I was able to
learn about how
people are able to move money to
make actual change in society.
And there are actually
some really great groups
who are looking into
this, such as the Daphne
Foundation, the Surdna
Foundation, and just
a whole bunch of different
philanthropic groups
who are actually looking at
how this money is being spent.
And they're actually funding
great groups, such as Exalt.
And philanthropy, I
think, is a great way
to learn more about
what's going on
and to actually
make a difference.
JONATHAN PRIESTER: On behalf
of Google and the Black Googler
Network, I want to thank
you all for taking your time
to be here with us today.
Let's give another round of
applause to our performers.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN LEWIS: Thank you.
JONATHAN PRIESTER: And
I think if anything--
if we can take away
anything from today,
it's that action can be taken
right now, that no one needs
to wait.
There's amazing
groups like Exalt
that need our support,
that need our help,
and that are doing really,
really amazing work.
And you can see the brilliant
product that is being produced.
So thank you all again.
Thank you all for
coming, and thank you.
[APPLAUSE]